In this intermediate OpenGL course, it Ty
will teach you about skeletal animation using
3d models. Hi, my name is Italian, I'd like to
welcome you to a course on skeletal animation in
OpenGL. If you have some experience with OpenGL,
and you want to learn how to load an enemy 3d
model files such as FBX x, which is used in unity,
then this is the course for you. The course is
composed of two main sections. In the first one,
we learn how to load models using the SNP library.
And the second section is actually made up of
five parts, where we implement skeletal animation,
step by step, I consider the material here to be
intermediate level. So you should be familiar with
the common 3d transformations, setting up vertex
and index buffers and writing shaders to do basic
lighting. If you need some ramp up on these
topics, you will find beginner level tutorials
on my YouTube channel and on my website, as well
as resources by other creators as well, of course,
you'll find links in the video description below
the programming language of the course in C++.
So you should be familiar with it. But don't
worry, you don't need to be a C++ expert. I'm
using very basic stuff such as glasses, and no
fancy stuff from C++ 20, or anything like that.
In terms of operating system. I'm running Linux
as my main development to us. But you can also use
Windows Of course, you'll find all the sources in
GitHub, and I'll include Visual Studio solutions
as well. So without further ado, let's get into
it. Welcome back to jail live, I guess it's quite
clear that there is a limit to the complexity
of a manually created model. The pyramid is
okay. And cube is also okay. But when it comes
to modeling something from the physical world,
you need some help there. That's why we
have software like blender, Maya, 3ds,
Max, and many many other tools that allow you to
create models in a sophisticated 3d environment.
With lots of supporting tools that help the
modeling artists create the amazing 3d worlds
and objects that we are used to in modern
games. The modeling software takes care of
calculating the position texture coordinates and
any other vertex attributes that you may need.
It also groups the vertices into triangles and
manages the corresponding indices. And finally,
the modeling software saves all this data to file
so you'll be able to load the model in your game
or application and manipulate it using OpenGL or
any other 3d API. It will probably not surprise
you that since there are many 3d modelers, we
also have lots of formats for the model files.
Choose a partial list. So if you want to load
these model files into your game, you can either
write a custom loader yourself or use an existing
library for that. If you like writing everything
from scratch, then you're welcome to write such
a parser on your own. But my recommendation is to
go with an existing solution because it will save
you a lot of time. In this video, we're going to
use the open asset import library or SMP, which
is a free and open source library that is very
easy to use and supports many file formats. SMP
takes care of parsing the model file, which by
the way can be text or binary, and loads it into
its own native data structure in memory. What we
need to do is to use this data structure in order
to populate OpenGL vertex and index buffers. Load
any textures that may also be present and
set up the layout of the vertex attributes.
Let's start by installing SMP and we have several
options here. Depending on the operating system.
I'll include the instructions for everything that
you are going to see in the video description.
If you're on Linux Ubuntu, you can simply
execute the following command to install SMP.
If you want to build SMP yourself,
you'll need to clone the following repo.
CD into the new directory and execute C make
space.if You don't have CMake installed you can
easily install it using sudo apt install Simic. At
this point, you may run into various difficulties
mostly due to missing packages. Let me know of
any issues in the comments and I'll try to help
as much as I can. You can also use the support
forum on the GitHub page. If CMA completed
successfully you can execute make and then
sudo make install to complete the installation.
Now you need to integrate SMP into your build
process. As you probably know, I'm using
simple bash scripts to build my sources. In these
scripts, I'm using package config to get the build
and link parameters. So all I need to do is to
add a sign p as a parameter to the command package
config dash dash c flags to get the include
directory and package config dash dash libs to get
the link command. The results of the two commands
are provided as parameters to g plus plus below.
Package config is very handy because its behavior
is tailored to the distribution that it is running
on, which makes it very flexible. On Windows,
you also have two options, you can use the
binary is provided with my source repo or you
can build the source yourself. Unfortunately,
it seems that prebuilt binaries for windows
are no longer available from the SMP website.
Okay, so if you want to use the binaries that I've
created, you can go to the old jail dev directory,
go to windows down here. And in the lib directory,
you will find that this file is sent PVC 142 Empty
dot lib, that's the library that you need to link
against its release built of SMP and you also need
the DLL for runtime, which is in this directory
DLL. It's the same file just with the extension
DLL, okay. And you will also need all the headers
that we have here at old jail dev slash include,
we have SNMP. And that's all the headers of this
library checked in right here. That's the latest
version at this time. Now, if you want to build
the sources yourself, you need to check them
out using gate. I'm using Tor to his gate. And
I've explained how to install it in a previous
tutorial, the one about Windows support, so
you can find it there. So what you need to do
is right click in some directory and then get
clone. And here's the address of the website,
which by default will go to this SNP directory.
Now I don't need to press OK, because I already
got it checked out right here. So let's go
inside. And here you can shift right click
and go to Open PowerShell window here. And you
will also need C make installed just type C make
C make lists dot txt and run it and it will
generate the Visual Studio solution file
which we can find right here SMP
dot SLN. So let's open this one.
And here it can select whether you want
the debug or the release version. As they
said what is checked into the old jail
dev source repo is the release version
and make sure that you're using x 64. And then you
just need to do build and rebuild solution okay.
Okay, the build is complete. So we can
go back to SMP slash lib. And the Select
debug or release whatever you use to build in
this case, release. So we have this file here,
which is exactly the one with which is checked
into the origin of source repo and also
in slash bin, we have the DLL, okay. Okay, now
go to your project. Right click it properties.
Let's go to linker and input. And here in the
additional dependencies, we have the s&p lib file,
you will also need to make sure that in C++,
general you will have the include directory here
as the additional Include Directories
now, I've already got this directory from
from all the previous project, which is going
up three directories and include from the
location of the project. Okay, so if we go to
the location of the Visual Studio project file,
in our jail there have windows or jail dev vs
2019. We have the project right here. So we're
going up three directories. And here we've
got include, and here's the SMP headers. So
when we include the headers, we can simply write
this directive right here because this references,
the include directory that we just saw. And we
also need to make sure that the DLL file can
be accessed during runtime. So let's go to the
project properties again, and go to debugging.
And here we can see that I've added the location
of the DLL directory right here. So now we can
run it. Now let's dive into the code and I will
explain the structure of a cmp as we go along.
Okay, so first, I created a class called Basic
mesh that represents a model loaded using a cmp.
This class is declared in OpenGL dev
basic metadata h in the include directory.
We have several public and private functions
here, as well as a few private variables.
We'll revisit these items as we go through the
class. Now let's go to the implementation of
this class in ojio, def basic mesh dot CPP
in the common directory. The first function
I'd like to review is load mesh, which is
a public function that takes the file name
as a parameter and serves as the top level
entry point for the entire loading process.
The first function call inside this function
is to declare a private function. This function
clears all the internal data structure of the
class, allowing you to reuse the same class
object for loading a different model. We're not
going to use this capability in this tutorial,
so I'll just keep it next regenerate and bind
the vertex array object for the current model.
We've covered videos in the previous tutorial, so
make sure you watch that for more details. Next,
we generate six OpenGL buffer objects and buffers
is a private array of six unsigned integers.
In this tutorial, we're going to see a
different method of storing vertices.
What we've been using so far is a method known
as array of structures or aos. The core element
in this method is a structure that contains
vertex attributes such as position, texture
coordinates, normals, etc. For storing multiple
vertices, we have an array of this structure,
hence the name array of structures. This arrays
loaded into the open GL buffer, which means that
the attributes are interleaved, they're in the
exact same way as in CPU memory. The second method
and the one that I'm going to demonstrate today
is a structure of arrays or SOA. Here we have a
separate array for each of the attributes.
Okay, so we have an array of positions,
array of texture, coordinates, and so on, we can
group these arrays together in a single structure.
As the name structure of arrays, the arrays must
all be of the same length. So in order to access
all the attributes of a single vertex, we need to
use the same index to access each of the arrays.
OpenGL allows us to use both methods to build
up our 3d objects. We use an enum to access
each buffer by its name or other than an obscure
number. So the first buffer is the index buffer,
we have the position at index one texture
coordinates at index two, and normal let index
three normal vectors are required for lighting
effects. For now, this is just a placeholder. So
if you're writing this code yourself, you can drop
it. The last two buffers W, VP, math VB and World
Map VB are also placeholders. They will be used
in the future when we get to instancing. Back to
load mesh, we can see that we're initializing all
the buffers in a single call to GL Gen buffers.
By the way, array size in elements is a handy
macro for calculating the number of elements
in an array by dividing the size of the
array by the size of the first element,
which must always exists. In order to access
the services of SMP, we define an object of
the importer class which is defined in the SMP
namespace. To get this compiled, we must include
three files from the SMP include directory,
importer, dot HPP, scene dot h and postprocess
dot h, we actually load the model we call importer
dot read file passing in the model file name,
and the list of SNP flags which is wrapped inside
this SNP load flags macro. These flags allow us to
modify the behavior of SMP so let's quickly go
over them. First, we have to triangulate flag.
Many modeling tools allow you to build models
using polygons with more than three vertices,
we must use triangles. So this flag tells this MP
to split these polygons into triangles. Jen smooth
normals is for lighting. So let's keep it for now.
Clip UV flips the texture coordinates along the V
or the y axis of the texture. This is something
that you may need to play with to make this work
with your models because some modelers will allow
you to control this when exporting the model.
And finally, we want the same pay to
join identical vertices and adjust the
index buffer accordingly. This will save
us some memory. There are many more flags
available in the SNP postprocess dot h header
and you can find the full documentation online.
This is actually one of the reasons why SNP is so
flexible. If read file returns now then the call
has failed and we print the error using important
dot get error string. Else we get back a pointer
to an object of the AI scene class. And we call
init from scene to continue the initialization.
A scene is the top level data structure in the
memory representation of the model that SMP
created. As usual before we leave this function,
we unbind our V O from the OpenGL state. And let's
continue with the init from scene which is defined
below this function. The way that the AI scene is
structured is that it matches the behavior of most
modelers that enable you to split up the model
into subcomponents. This allows you to apply some
transformation on one component without affecting
the others. So you can have a head and arm a
sword and whatever. If the model is split into
sub components SMP creates an AI mesh structure
for each component. This AI mesh contains all the
vertices and indices of that component. The number
of AI mesh structures is given in the M num meshes
variable The AI scene class, we reserve a matching
number of elements in our private variable meshes,
which is a vector of basic mesh entry. Basic mesh
entry contains a few variables that we will need
to maintain for each AI mesh, such as the number
of vertices, base vertex, etc. We're going to see
these soon. A scene can also contain textures,
and SAP reps one or more textures in something
which it calls materials. These are stored in an
array of AI material structures. And the size of
this array is given in m&m materials. We have a
matching vector of pointers to our texture class,
we reserve space there accordingly. Now,
here's the plan, we're going to stack up all
the vertices and indices from all the AI mesh
structures in the buffers we've just created,
according to their type, index, position,
texture, coordinates, etc. However,
each AI mesh may use a different texture, but we
can switch textures in the middle of a draw call.
This means that we need to launch a draw call
for each a mesh separately, and this will give
us the opportunity to switch textures as needed
between draw calls. This also means that we cannot
use GL draw elements. Because this function only
draws vertices from the beginning of the buffer,
we need a more sophisticated function that allows
us to draw from different offsets within the
buffer. And OpenGL provides us with such a draw
function. Okay, so in order to actually allocate
space in our index and vertex buffers, we need
to know how many vertices and indices there are
in the entire scene object. Unfortunately,
these are not readily available to us,
so we need to actually count them. We do this in
the private function count vertices and indices,
which also updates the meshes array, we just need
to loop over the elements in the meshes array that
we've just resized. For each element, we copied
the material index from the corresponding a mesh,
we calculate the number of indices in the current
mesh by multiplying the number of faces by three,
since after triangulation, all the polygons are
now triangles, the base vertex is the index of
the first vertex of the current mesh in our global
buffers. To calculate it, we increment number this
is by the number of vertices in the AI mesh, we
calculate the base index in a similar fashion by
incrementing num indices by the number of indices
of the current mesh that we've just calculated. So
for example, if we have three meshes with 100 250
vertices, then the first mesh is at offset zero,
the second mesh is at offset 100. And the last
one is at offset 300. When we exit the function,
both num vertices and indices contain the totals
for each type. When we're back to Unit from scene,
we call reserved space with the two counters.
This function allocates space in four vectors
for the positions, texture, coordinates, normals,
and indices. These vectors are private members of
the class, they will be used to accumulate all
the further says from the AI scene structure.
So we can load each OpenGL buffer with a single
call to GL buffer data. Back to load mesh,
we call it all meshes, which simply reverses
all the SMP mesh structures and calls in each
single match for each one. In this function, we
actually populate the vectors that we just saw
with vertex and index data. We do this by going
over all the vertices in the a mesh and extracting
the position normal and textural coordinates
from their respective location in the AI mesh.
Notice that these items are represented by SMP
API vector 3d, which is very similar to our vector
class. In the case of the texture coordinate,
we must also check that it exists in if not use
the zero vector instead, we can now populate our
vectors with this data. Also, notice that in the
case of the texture coordinates, we only use the X
and Y out of the 3d vector populating the indices
is very similar. The mesh contains an array of
triangles called M faces. Each AI face structure
contains the three indices, which we need to push
into the indices vector. The next function that
you need from sin calls is you need materials.
This is where we allocate GL textures for the
images in the model. The image files are stored
in the same directory as the main model file. So
first, we need to extract the directory
of the model file. This is done by simple
parsing of the last slash character. We can now
to reverse the Materials array in the SMP scene.
Material is basically a container for multiple
textures, and it may contain diffuse specular
and ambient textures, as well as stuff like a
height map, normal map and etc. These are required
for more advanced stuff like lighting, for basic
texturing we just need the diffuse texture. So we
check whether it exists by calling get texture on
the material with the AI texture type. underscore
diffuse enum. In the first parameter, the second
parameter is zero because we only want the first
texture. The third parameter is an address of an
AI string variable, where the path of the texture
will be returned if it exists. Of course, right
now we don't need the rest of the parameters. So
we have nulls. There. If the call was successful,
we construct the full path of the texture file.
Inside the model, the path of the texture is
relative to the location of the model file. Now
we can create our texture object as usual and load
it. Let's go back to knit from scene for the last
time. And the final call here is to the private
function populate buffers. And this is where we
prepare stuff for using SOA. We start by binding
the position buffer to the GL array buffer target
to make it current, we load the data from the
vector into the buffer by calling GL buffer data.
The number of bytes is obtained by multiplying
the size of the first element by the number of
elements in the vector. The base address is the
address of the first element and we use GL static
draw, because we don't plan on updating the buffer
again. Next, we enable the vertex attribute for
the position. At the top of this file, we
have macros for the location of the three
vertex attributes. It's not the most robust design
because we must keep this in sync with the shader,
but it will do for now. Next, we configure the
layout of the position buffer by calling GL vertex
three pointer. Again, we use the macro for the
index of the attribute, we have three floats here,
JL falls for no need to normalize, and the
last two parameters are now zero. Previously,
we had to put here the size of the entire vertex
structure, and the offset of the current attribute
inside the vertex. Since the positions are packed
one after the other, we can now put zeros here
because the driver already knows everything from
the three floats. We repeat the same process
for the texture coordinates and the normals. And
every time we call GL vertex a three pointer, the
drivers stores the address of the buffer, which is
currently bound to GL array buffer for the current
attribute. This enables each attribute to come
from different buffer. Okay, so SOA structure of
arrays. Finally, we populate the indices, just
remember to use GL element array buffer for the
target here. Congratulations, we are done with
uploading the model. The only thing that we have
left here is of course, the render function, we
start by binding the V of this model, this brings
in the vertex layout that we've just created.
Next, we traverse our internal meshes array,
we get the material index, and we check whether
we have a corresponding element in the texture
array because there may be a material without a
diffuse texture. If there is a texture we bind it,
color texture unit is simply a macro for GL
texture zero that I keep in OpenGL dev engine
common dot h, I'm using this file in order to keep
the tutorials somewhat consistent. Now comes the
interesting part. Instead of GL draw elements, we
use GL draw elements base vertex that allows us to
draw sub regions of the vertex and index buffers.
The first parameter is gL triangles as usual.
The second parameter is the number of indices
of the current mesh, which we've calculated
when we loaded the model. Next is the data
type of the index unsigned int in our case,
next is the offset to the first index of the
current mesh in the index buffer. So we multiply
the base index of the current mesh by the size
of an unsigned int. In order to get the offset,
we also need to cast it to void pointer. I
think this is due to some historical issue
with this function. The last parameter is
the base vertex for the current draw call.
You see, the original indices that we got from
SMP started at zero in each AI mesh structure,
but we decided to stack up all the vertices in a
single buffer per attribute. This messes up the
indexing, one solution would be to adjust each
index based on the starting position of the mesh
in our single buffer. A more simple solution is
to use this last parameter here as a base Vertex.
This number will be added to each index so that
it will match the offset inside our buffer.
For example, let's say that we have two AI
meshes. The indices have both meshes started zero,
but each mesh obviously refers to its own set of
vertices. we stack up the two vertex groups one
after the other and let's say that the size of
the first group is 100. So the base vertex for
the second group will be calculated as 100. When
we render the second group we will pass in 100
in this last parameter, so that index zero will
become 100 index, one will become 101, and etc.
So we have a sub set of indices that started some
offset inside the index buffer. And to each index,
OpenGL will automatically add whatever we put as
the base vertex. All these elements were already
calculated when loading the model. So they
are now ready when we get here. Okay, so we
have a series of draw calls here. Each draw call
uses a subset of the index and vertex buffers.
And before each draw call, we have an opportunity
to switch textures. Now let's see the changes in
the main application code. In the tutorial
18 class, I got rid of all the videos,
videos, and index buffer that they used to keep
around here as well as the world transform object.
Instead, we just need a single pointer to
basic mesh. In the init method, we need to
call the mesh with the path of the model file.
In the main render function, we perform all the
transformations on the wall trans object that
we have in the basic mesh class. So if we have
multiple meshes, it makes it simple to keep the
transformation of each mesh inside its own object.
Also, instead of calling GL draw elements,
we just need to call the render function
on the mesh object. This is basically all we
need to do here. Let's build and run this. Okay,
so this looks like a spider. But there's obviously
something wrong here, right? The problem is that
they haven't enabled the depth test. Without it,
the frame buffer works like a regular Canvas.
So whatever color you use last, that's the
color that you're actually going to get
on the final screen. With simple stuff
like the cube, we couldn't see the problem.
But with more complex models, the problem is
evident. I discussed the depth buffer in the
previous episode, so I won't repeat it here. By
enabling the depth test, we make sure that the
closest pixel is rendered. Regardless the order
of rendering. We do this by calling GL enable
with the GL depth this macro as a parameter, we
must also clear the depth buffer on every frame,
else it will contain garbage data from the
previous frame. So in the main render function,
we add the GL depth buffer bit with the bit mask
that we provide to the GL clear call. Okay, guys,
you can now go ahead and try to load different
models that you find for free online, or that you
create yourself if you know how, I can't guarantee
that this code is bulletproof and will work for
every model, it probably still contains some bugs,
please let me know if you run into a problem.
Welcome back to jail then. In this tutorial, we're
starting to take a look at skeletal animation
and how to implement it in OpenGL skillfull.
animation or skinning is considered the standard
way of animating almost any living creature. And
it can also be used to animate monsters, aliens,
as well as various types of types of machines,
such as robots. Therefore, it is a core technique
in game development. So over the course of the
next few tutorials, we're going to do a deep dive
into it. Si MP, the library that we've been using
to load models has very good support for skeletal
animation across several file types. So we will
take advantage of it. The way that I'm going to
cover this subject is going to be very hands on
oriented. I'll provide an overview of the process
and the technique. And then we'll basically jump
back and forth between the code and the theory.
We'll understand some part of the algorithm and
then see how to implement it in C++ using OpenGL.
And then back to theory and etc. I'm going to use
Blender as the modeling tool. So for simplicity,
I'll just use the name blender. But of course, all
the other major modeling tools support skillful
animation as well. Just to clarify, I'm not an
artist. But for the purpose of developing this
mini series. I did spend some time studying
blender because I think that the familiarity
with the tool where you create and animate the
model gives you better and better understanding
of the developer part in this process. Now let's
take the human body. As an example. As you're
probably aware, 70% of our body is water, which is
why we are so flexible, the bones are wrapped by
flesh and the flesh is wrapped by the skin.
So basically, you can say that the skin is
carried or held by the bones. Now this is not
going to be a lesson in anatomy. All I'm saying
is that the idea behind skeletal animation is
pretty much borrowed from the real world. All
the models that we've been using so far have
been simply the exterior representation of a
real world object. Inside the object. There is
nothing so In the context of skeletal animation,
we call the model itself the skin, which is
why this technique is also called skinning.
The bones are the skeleton, which kind of
carries the skin like in the real world.
But since we don't have any flesh in our
model between the skeleton and the skin,
the replacement that blender provides is simply a
list of vertices that are affected by each bone.
This means that when the bone is animated, or to
put it in a language, which is more common to us,
when it is translated and rotated, the same
transformation which is applied to the bone
must be applied on the vertices that are affected
by it. For example, when the bone of an arm is
translated, and rotated, the part of the mash that
represents that arm is translated and rotated. To
follow the movement and rotation of the bone.
Calculating the transformations that must be
applied on the vertices due to the movement of
the bones is the major goal of this technique,
it is important to understand that only the skin
gets rendered and not a skeleton. The job of the
skeleton and the bones is simply to help us
define the range of movement that is available
to the skin. For example, the angle between
the arm and the forearm can range between zero,
quote unquote when the two limbs touch each other,
and then in the 180 degrees when the forearm is
fully stretched. Beyond that the elbow will break.
Not nice, the processing blender of placing the
virtual bones inside the skin, making them in
the proper length to fit the specific body part
and connecting them together into a skeleton
is called rigging. Skinning is the process
where you connect the vertices to the skeleton and
define the amount by which each vertex is affected
by the bones. The last piece of the puzzle
is animating. And this is where you use the
available controls placed during the reading phase
in order to create a set of keyframes that define
the movement of the bones of the bones. Over time,
skeletal animation has two main characteristics
that help us mimic the real world movement. First,
the skeleton defines the hierarchy of bones,
most bones will have a parent. So when the
parent bone moves, the child bone follows this
relationship is one way the child may move without
affecting the parent. Second, each vertex may be
affected by more than one bone. This means that
when one or more bones move, the transformation
of the vertices that are influenced by these
bones must somehow combine the transformations
of each bone. Actually, if you have a model where
every vertex is fully controlled by a single bone,
then that model is probably that of a robot or any
other type of machine. A car is a simple example,
you can use skeletal animation to animate the
opening and closing of car doors. The door is
connected to the car by some kind of metal joint.
But when the door opens, the only vertices that
are moving belong to the door, the rest of the car
stays exactly where it is, this is definitely not
the case with living creatures. Here we want the
model to deform in a way that will simulate deal
assisity of the skin. This behavior is most
evident around the joints. Skillful animation
allows us a high degree of flexibility in terms
of calculating the movement of each vertex
based on all the balls that are affected. We do
this by assigning a weight to each combination
of a bone and a vertex the way it is a fraction
between zero and one. And the sum of all weights
per vertex should be one, we do the calculation as
a linear combination of the bone transformations
and their weights. For example, if the weight
of two bones affecting one vertex is a half,
it means that the vertex is equally influenced by
both bones and its movement will be the average
of the movement of the two bones. If one way
it is point nine and the other is point one, it
means that the vertex is probably much closer to
the first bone so it will go along with it. But
there will still be some minor influence coming
in from the second bone that may pull it a bit
towards a different direction. Blender provides
the artist with powerful tools to set the weights
of the different bones. Most artists will probably
start with an automatic assignment of weights in
this method, Blender calculates the weights based
on the distance between the vertex and each bone.
The next step will be to review the result and
start fixing and adjusting and tuning the model
using weight painting. Weight painting is a
feature in Blender where you increase or decrease
the weights of vertices for the selected bone by
going over them with a special brush. Usually,
the artist will develop the skin first and then
structure the skeleton inside it. It makes sense
because the bones must match the dimension of
the body part that will actually get rendered.
At this stage before the animation processes
started. The posture of the skin is called
Bind Pose. This is very important because all the
underlying transformations and math will reference
the Bind Pose as a starting position. There
are no restrictions in terms of how the model
should look like in Bind Pose. But the common
practice is to keep the model in this kind of
relaxed posture without too many bendings
in the area of the joints. If you search for
skillful animation Bind Pose in Google Images,
you will find many examples of this posture
for the human or semi human models, with the
arms kind of stretched to the sides and the
legs are straight and relaxed. When you render
the model without applying any animation on it,
you should get it in Bind Pose. Once rigging
and skinning have been completed, the model is
ready for animation. Naturally, the same set of
bones can be used for multiple sets of animation.
Think about all the possibilities the human body
provides in terms of movement and flexibility. All
this is achieved with just 206 bones. Even with
a small subset of these bones in a human model,
you can still implement many animations. Therefore
each animation set will simulate some kind of
activities such as walking, running, fighting,
etc. An animation set is composed of a series of
transformations that are applied on the skeleton
as the artist animates it. These transformations
may include as usual scaling, rotation and
translation. In the case of humans in many
other living creatures, we will only encounter
rotation and translation. But the technique itself
can support animated scaling of bones as well.
The transformations will be provided at regular
intervals according to some frame rate. For
example, a 10 second animation and 24 frames per
second will include 240 sets of transformations,
these sets are usually very close. So if the
actual frame rate in the game is higher than
the animation frame rate, we can interpolate
between consecutive transformations and get the
final animation. Since these transformations
represent the changes in the orientation of the
bones, we can apply them on the vertices that are
influenced by these bones and basically animate
the model. Okay, this is enough theory for now.
I've left out many details that we will need
for the full implementation. But at this stage,
I'd like to get our hands dirty with some code.
Now skeletal animation is supported by various
file types. And if you implement the loader,
for a specific file type, you will probably
need your skeletal animation code to adhere
to the conventions of that file type. However,
since we are using SNMP, we only need our code
to adhere to the conventions and specifics
of this library. And by that, we'll be able to
support many file types. As I said, we're going to
implement these techniques step by step in hands
on approach. So let's create a simple utility
that will parse the data structures created by
SMP and extract the relevant parts from it later,
we will incorporate this logic into our OpenGL
application. Now this utility is not required for
the actual execution of the animation, but will
be very useful for debugging etc. So this utility
is composed of a single file, which I call the CMP
sandbox cpp. And we've also got a build script in
the same directory called the build SNP sandbox
to build it, and it is very simple. We have the
build flags right here called CPP flags. And for
now, I've included only dash g gdb. Three in order
to build it with debug information for debugging.
And we've also got the link flags called LD flags,
which is a call to package config dash dash libs
SNP. I'm often using package config in my build
scripts in order for my code to hopefully compile
on as many machines and systems as possible.
Okay, so if you run this on the command line,
package config dash dash libs a cmp. In this case
on my machine, he tells you that the link
command is dash l si MP and on other systems,
it may generate a different command. Okay,
and the final build command is very simple,
we call g plus plus the name of the CPP
file, the compiler flags, the link flags
dash O and the name of the binary. Okay,
so now let's take a look at the CPP file.
And by the way, I have a video on loading models
using SNP so definitely check that out. If you
want more details. I'll go over the major details
in this video. Okay, so first we need to include
these three headers for SMP. Okay, let's
scroll down to the bottom. And here we have
your standard main function, we're checking the
number of parameters here and needs to be two,
because there's a single parameter to this
utility, which is the model file name. Okay,
so if that's not the case, we simply exit
the utility. Next we pick up the file name
from location one in the arg v array. And we
define an object of the SMP importer class,
which basically handles all the s&p parsing stuff.
Next, we call read file on the importer object
using the file name and the load flag for s&p
which I defined. For convenience right here. And
this is pretty standard. We've done this already,
triangulate all the polygons in the mesh generate
normals and join identical vertices, we check
for error, and we call porcine using the returned
AI scene object from read file. So a
scene is the main object that handles
all our interaction with SMP and it
has several interesting functions,
as well as members that we can access. In this
case, we're going directly to the to the meshes,
okay, there is array, an array of API mesh
object, which is where all the vertices live,
and the indices as well as the bones. So porcine
is very simple, it just calls parse meshes
with the scene object. And in the future, we
will have a function to handle the hierarchy
and the animations. Okay, so this will grow
and develop over the next few tutorials.
So we have parse meshes here. And we start by
printing the number of meshes in the scene object,
which you can find in the M num meshes attribute
in the scene. Next, we prepare a few counters.
For the total number of vertices, indices
and bonds, we loop over the number of meshes,
and we extract each Mesh from the
meshes array based on the index,
we take the number of vertices, we calculate
the number of indices, which is the number of
faces time three, because we've triangulated, all
the polygons and we also access num bones. Okay,
so in the AI mesh structure, we have an array of
bones right here. And we have the number of bones
in this attribute, M num bones. Next, we
calculate the total number of vertices
in decision bonds, which we're going to print at
the end of this function. And this is mostly for
informative purposes, just to make sure that
everything everything is working correctly.
The important pieces here, where we call has
bones, which is a Boolean function that tells us
whether this mesh has any bones in it. And then
we call parse mesh bones on the specific mesh that
we're currently processing. So now let's go to
parse mesh bones, which is up here. And this is
also very simple, we loop over the number of
bones in this mesh, and we call parse single
bone. Now if we run this right now, and we'll
use a model, which is checked into my repo,
called Bob lamb clean, and the five mesh, which is
by the way, from Doom three, and you can see that
it tells us that there are six meshes. And these
are the names of the meshes. Okay, we have a body,
a face, a helmet, grill, grill, and another
body. And for each mesh, we can see the number
of vertices and indices. And this is the important
thing here, the number of bones Okay, so the body
has 28 bones, and the face has just two bones.
And these guys have one bone, and the last one
has two bones. Okay, and if we load it in Blender,
we can actually see right here on the right hand
side that these meshes correspond to components
of the mesh inside blender. So we have the grill
which this guy is holding, and we have the body.
Okay, and this part of the body is actually
the sword, the face and the helmet. Okay, so now
let's see, parse mesh bones, which is right here.
And this is a simple loop over the number of bones
in the mesh, and we're calling parse single bone
for each bone. From this array and we'll also
we're also passing in the index of the bone
which we will later see. So let's see what we have
in this AI bone structure. And there are only four
public attributes. Okay, we have the name of the
bone, which is used for informative purposes, as
you saw in blender, you want to name the bones, so
you will be able to remember what it's supposed to
do. And we have the number of weights here, which
is actually the number of elements in this array,
and weights. Okay, we'll see that in a second,
we have an attribute called M offset matrix,
which is a four by four matrix. And he
tells us that this matrix transforms
from mesh space to bone space in Bind Pose.
Okay, so this may sound a bit intimidating,
but we will see how to use that in a future video.
And the last attribute is the M weights array,
which is of the AI vertex weight structure. And
this structure contains just two attributes. Okay,
so every element in the structure has a vertex
ID, which tells us the index of the vertex
that is influenced by this bone, and the strength
of that influence, which must be in the range zero
to one as we talked about earlier. So in the
parse single bone function, we loop over the
number of weights in the bone, and we extract the
vertex weight element from the M weights array,
and let me just uncomment all these printf
calls, were basically printing the vertex ad,
and the weight. Now let's run this again. And
now we're getting the list of bones for each mesh
as well as the verses that are influenced by it.
Okay, so here we can see that the first bone bones
zero is called pubis and the number of vertices
affected by this bone is 190. And here we can see
all the all the indices of these vertices as
well as the weights okay. So we can see that
this model is actually very simple. So when
we glanced through this, it seems like when a
vertex is influenced by two bones, then the
weight of each bone will be a half and if
it is influenced by three bones, then the
weight will be a third, okay, so always,
the weight for each bone will be the same as
the other bones, okay, so it averages out.
And here's the next bone which is pelvis
254 verses than the spine, and it continues
like that. So the total number of bones is
35. This brings us to the first challenge,
each bone is mapped to the vertices that it
influences and many vertices are influenced
by multiple bones. But skeletal animation
is implemented in the vertex shader, because
this is basically the only place where we can
actually change the position of vertex. Therefore,
what we really need is a reverse mapping from each
vertex to the bones that influence it. This info
must be provided to the vertex shader, so that we
can calculate the transformation of each vertex
based on all these bones. All this and
more will be covered in the next tutorial.
Okay, quick recap. from part one, we
created a small utility to load the
bond related stuff from SMP SMP holds the model
in one or more mesh structures, and each mesh
points to an array of bones and each bone points
to an array of the vertices that it influences.
For each vertex, we have an index and the weight,
which is a floating point number between zero
and one that represents the amount by which the
current bone influences this vertex. At the end of
part one, I left you with the challenge of mapping
the vertices back to the bones that influenced
them. Okay, so maybe it was a bit too dramatic.
Anyway, this video is going to be very technical,
and the focus will be on implementing this mapping
and making sure that it is working correctly.
Now since the core principle in this mini series
is to work in a step by step fashion, we're going
to implement it first in the SMP utility, and
then move this logic over to the main application.
I also want to visualize the relation between
the bones and the vertices. So in today's demo,
you'll be able to actually see the effect that
each bone has over the vertices. In this example,
the red triangles represent vertices that are
highly influenced by the current bone, and this
influence decreases as we move from red to yellow,
and then to green. The blue triangles represent
vertices that don't receive any influence from
the current bone. You can click the space bar
and switch between the different Bones. This
part of the fragment shader is not required
in the final implementation. But I think that
if you're implementing this in your own code,
it will be a good debugging step, just to make
sure that everything is loaded correctly into the
GPU. Okay, so let's jump back into SMP sandbox dot
cpp. And we start by including the map string in
vector headers from the C++ standard library for
the data structures that we will need here. Next,
we have a macro, which defines the maximum number
of balls per vertex four balls is enough for
my model. So just tweak this to make it match
your assets. Next, we have the vertex bone data
structure that contains two arrays, one for the
indices of all the bones that affect this vertex.
And for each bone, we also have the corresponding
weight. I'll skip the rest of the structure for
now. Next, we have three new data structures, we
have a vector of the vertex bone data for each
vertex. This is basically the mapping from the
vertices back to the bones that influence them.
We have a vector of integers called MeSH base
vertex. Yes, NPC in class contains meshes,
which contain balls, and each bone references the
vertices of the mesh, in which it is contained,
as if they start at zero, we're going to pack
all the vertices together in a single array
called vertex two bones. So we want to map the
relative vertex index to a unique global vertex
index. And we do that by calculating a base vertex
for each mesh and adding the relative vertex index
to this base. Finally, we have a map from bone
names to their indices, because SNP uses strings
for the name of the bones. But for us, it will
be much more straightforward to work with bone
indices. So now let's jump down to main. And
we've seen this in part one. So very briefly,
main calls porcine, which calls, parse meshes.
And here we resize mesh base vertex using the
number of meshes in the scene. So for each mesh,
we have a base index, which we need to calculate.
And we do this right here, the total number of
vertices in is increased for each mesh. So before
we increase it, for the current mesh, we save the
current total number of vertices as the base, we
also resize vertex to bones based on the updated
total number of vertices, because we're going to
need this space when we parse the mesh. Now,
this is not the most efficient way to do this.
But for utility like that, this is okay.
Basically, this vector is resized again and again,
for each new mesh with just
enough space for this mesh.
Finally, we call parse mesh bones. And you may
notice that I added the index of the current mesh,
because we're going to need it later. First mesh
bones didn't change, we simply call for a single
bone for each bone with the addition of the mesh
index in the first parameter. In part one, this
function simply printed all the vertices that are
affected by the current bone and their weights.
I added some code here to create the mapping
from the vertices back to the bones. First,
we get the bone ID, which is a unique
index for each bone. Inside the loop,
we calculate the global vertex ID by adding the
vertex ID from the AI vertex weight structure
to the base vertex ID of the current mesh, which
we set in the past meshes function. Right here.
Each mesh has a batch of vertices
and the balls that reference them
use indices that start at zero, we want to stack
up all the indices of all these batches together,
one after the other, because we're loading it
like that to the vertex buffer. So we have to make
these indices unique. So the first batch starts at
zero, and then the base of the next batch starts
with wherever the previous batch ended. Let's jump
to get bone ID, which maps the name of the bone to
its unique index. We have a map between a string
and an integer called Bone name to index map.
If the name already exists, we just return the
index. And if not, we set the mapping and the
bone Id simply increments automatically as we add
more items into the map back to parse single mesh.
Now that we have the global vertex ad, we use
it to access the vertex two bones array, which
I remind you is a vector of vertex bone data
structure. And we call Add Bone data with the
index of the current bone and the weight which
is coming from the AI vertex weights structure.
This function searches for a free slot in the
weights array and places the bone ID and the
weight in that slot. We assume that if The weight
is zero, then this slot is free because the weight
must be greater than zero with the bone actually
influences that vertex. Once we find the free
slot and do the update, we can actually
the function, if we can find a free slot,
there will be an assertion because either
you have a bug, or you need to increment
the maximum number of bones per vertex. Now let's
run this on our Bob lamb clean.md. Five mesh file.
And you can see that we get the vertex ID, the
bone index, the weight and the index of the slot,
where this info was recorded. Let's do
a bit of OHLC magic, let's grab vertex
and have oak printed just the values in this line.
Okay, so we have the vertex ID at index three,
bone index at five, weight at
seven and slot at nine works, okay.
We can solve this numerically by the vertex IDs
and we can see that the first vertex is fully
influenced by bone number two, the second vertex
is influenced by bones two and three. And we got
their weights at slot zero and one. So this
makes sense. Vertex eight is influenced by 11,
two and three. So this looks okay as well. If
you want, you can check this more thoroughly.
But I think that for now it is okay. The next step
will be to integrate this piece of logic into our
OpenGL application and actually load the indices
and weights of the bones per vertex into a vertex
buffer. We can then access it from the vertex
shader, and do cool stuff like applying some color
to all the pixels that are affected by a certain
bone. Again, this is just for debugging but we're
making progress in small steps and making sure
at each step that everything is working correctly
is very helpful. For the integration I copied all
GL def basic mesh header and cpp files into this
directory and I renamed them skinned mesh dot h
and cpp. The next tutorial, we'll include a new
version of the same files in its own directory,
so you'll be able to compare the two revisions
or jail death basic mesh was already covered in
a previous tutorial, I'll put a link below to
that video right now we'll just cover the skeletal
animation related code. This class is called Skin
mesh, same as the header. And here we have the max
number of bones per vertex. Vertex bone data is
here as a private declaration, and it is the same
one as in the sandbox, so no need to go over it,
we're going to use a new vertex buffer for
the bones in addition to the index position,
texture coordinates normals, so we have
in your enum for the bone vertex buffer,
we have the declarations of three functions
that I simply copied from the sandbox as these
load mesh bones load single bone and get bone ID,
I use the word load instead of parse because it
is more common. In this class, we have a vector
of vertex bone data, again same as the sandbox,
we're going to use it to populate a vertex buffer
of the bones. And finally, the map between the
bone name and it's index. Now let's go to the CPP
file, we have two new vertex attribute locations
for the vertex shader. This will allow each vertex
to access its list of bones and the weights make
sure to keep these numbers synchronized with the
vertex shader. In the reserved space function,
we are resizing the bone vector based on the
number of bones Okay, so this is the same
as all the other buffers here. In init single
mesh, I added a call to load mesh bones which
calls load single bones which uses get bone ID
to map the name of the bone tweets index. Okay,
so again, this works the same as in the SMP
utility. Basically, when the processing of
the scene structure is complete, we have
all the mapping from the vertices to bones
in this M bones vector, and then, in the Populate
buffers function, we bind and allocate the new
bone vertex buffer. We also enabled the two vertex
attributes to access the bone IDs and weights,
we also need to set the layout correctly. So
for the bone IDs, make sure to use GL int,
and not GL float as all the other attributes,
we have four integers for the four IDs,
followed by four floats, make sure to set the
offset correctly. For the second attribute,
we have the max number of bones times the size of
a bone ID, so we should get 16 Bytes here. Okay,
four bones times four bytes per integer. Now I
want to make sure that the bone vertex buffer is
populated and loaded correctly. So in this demo,
we will paint the triangles that are affected by
each bone using specific color. Let's see how to
do that. In the vertex shader, we have two new
input attributes for the bone IDs and the weights.
Notice that the IDs are AI vac and not a regular
veck. The regular veck is for floating points and
the IDs are integers. So we must use Ivic. The
vertex shaders simply copies the two attributes
out to the fragment shader. So we also need to
declare them as output attributes. Here, we need
the type qualifier flat. For the first time,
we're used to having the rasterizer interpolate
attributes such as colors and texture coordinates
across the triangle phase. But in the case of the
bone IDs, it doesn't make any sense. So this flat
qualifier basically tells the rasterizer don't
interpolate, simply copy the attribute as is,
we have a corresponding declaration in the
fragment shader. And we must use flat here as
well. If we forget it, we will get an error that
says that integer Vereine must be flat. The rest
of the fragment shader will simply copied from a
previous tutorial on lightning and the only change
is in the main function, we loop over the number
of bones and we check each slot in the bone IDs
attribute. Whether this is equal to display
bone index, which is a uniform attribute set
by the application, we're going to see that
in a minute. If this is true, we want to set
the output color and here, I tried to mimic the
behavior of Blender. Okay, so in Blender, if you
go to Weight Paint mode, you can switch between
the vertex groups, which is basically the bones
and then the blue vertices are not affected by the
selected bone at all. The red is highly affected
and the green and yellow are somewhere
in between. I tried to do a similar thing
in the fragment shader, okay, it's not perfect,
but it's pretty usable. If the weight of the
current bone is more than point seven, we output
red modulated by the way because it looks like
blender also uses the way to interpolate the color
between point four and point six, we use green
and then yellow for anything else above point one.
If the bone index is not found for this pixel,
we use blue. I also multiplied the original color
that comes from lighting by a small fraction,
in order to disable its effect that I didn't use
zero, so that the compiler will not yell at me,
the delighting stuff is not really used, the
application code is pretty standard, so no need
to go over everything. The only thing to note here
is that when spacebar is pressed, we increment
the current display bone index, we use modelu to
make sure we don't overflow the number of bones.
And then we set this index into the fragment
shader. The fragment shader has a uniform integer
for this index. And this is what we use for
checking the bone ID. So let's see how this works.
So the next step is to understand matrices
that control the transformation of the
vertices during the animation. All this and
more will be covered in the next tutorial.
In part one, and two, we learned how to load
the skeleton information using the SMP library.
And we created a mapping so that each vertex
can access the bones that influence it. Along
with the weights. We verified the implementation
using a simple demo that shows the triangles that
are influenced by selected bone. In this video,
we're going to study the core transformations,
or the skeletal animation technique. Remember that
in part one, we talked about how you create the
appearance of animation in Blender using a set
of keyframes where you adjust the location and
orientation of the bones in each keyframe. Now, if
this was a job interview, and they asked you Well,
given the way that blender works, how would you
implement animation in general, then I guess that
off the top of your head, you know, you could say
that you can save the position of all the vertices
in each frame. And then during runtime simply
render a different set of vertices in each frame.
Well, I guess this would work. But you can
obviously see the downsides of this approach.
This will probably blow up your model files, as
well as your vertex buffer or buffers. Therefore,
the approach taken by the actual algorithm is
to save a single set of positions specifically
in Bind Pose that we talked about in part one. In
addition, we associate a set of transformations
with each bone, one transformation for each
keyframe. During one time we perform a weighted
average of all the transformations that affect
each vertex. In practice, SNP actually saved the
transformations step Read items, one vector for
scaling and other vector for translation, and
the quaternion. For the rotation, we already know
how to create transformation matrices from these
guys. So no problem there, we only need to figure
out how to apply these matrices on the model.
Because it's not that straightforward. There is an
additional complexity from the fact that we want a
parent bone to affect the child bone, but not the
reverse. So if the finger moves, it doesn't affect
the hand. But when the hand moves, obviously,
the fingers also move. To understand how all this
works, we need to introduce a new coordinate
system, called the bone coordinate system,
or bone space, the origin of the bone coordinate
system is at the base of the bone. The bone itself
points along the y axis, and the X and Zed
axis are perpendicular to the Y axis and to
each other. Of course, you can turn on the display
of this coordinate system in Blender by selecting
the armature in the outlier. Going into Object
Data Properties tab and inside viewport display,
you have a checkbox called axis. We know that in
general, the vertices of the mesh are specified
in reference to a local coordinate system. So what
is the relationship between the local coordinate
system and the bone coordinate system? Well, the
bones form a hierarchy, which is a simple graph,
there is a root at the top and every node has
zero or more children, every node except the root
has a single parent. When rigging a new model,
the artist will designate some bone at the core
of the model as the root, the remaining bones will
branch out from this route and from each other.
In the case of a simple human model, it
makes sense to use the spine as the root,
and then the immediate children will be
the four limbs and the neck. From there,
you can continue down to the fingers, the bone
space of the root is specified in reference
to the local space. So you can think about
the local space as a primary coordinate system
with the origin 000 on the axis are as usual
100010 and 001, the base of the root bone will
be some point in this system, same as the regular
verses, and the root bone access will be vectors
in this system. In the following 2d example, the
origin of the bones space of the root is located
at one on the x and one on the y and the bone
space axes are some arbitrary unit vectors, things
become a bit more complex. When we move from the
root of the hierarchy to its immediate children,
the bone space of the children are defined in
reference to the root rather than the local space.
Going back to the example, we can see the root of
the hierarchy at one on the x and one on the Y.
And the base of the child bone is also at one on
the x and one on the on the Y but in reference
to its parent, which is the root. In reference to
local space, the child's bone is actually located
at two on the x and two on the Y. In this example,
I made the axis of the two bone spaces aligned
with the axis of local space to make it easier
for me to calculate everything in my head.
But obviously, it doesn't have to be this way.
By defining each bone space as a reference to its
parent, we can create a chain of transformations
that goes from each bone back to the root of the
hierarchy. A change in the transformation of a
node will obviously affect all of its descendants,
but not its parents. If you need an intuition
for how this works, you can take the model of
the universe as an example, you can trace the
orbit of the moon around the earth in a coordinate
system which is centered on the earth. The parent
of this coordinate system is obviously the one
where the Earth orbits around the Sun. So if
you want to calculate the location of the moon,
in reference to the sun, you need to take its
coordinates in the original system and multiplied
by transformation from the original system to the
coordinate system where the sun is at the origin.
The next step will be to multiply the result with
the transformation from the sun coordinate system
to the coordinate system where the sun
orbits around the center of the galaxy or
something like that. The final transformation
will be from the Galaxy coordinate system
to the universe coordinate system and this
will give you the coordinates of the moon
in the universe. So I'm not sure if professional
astronomers will approve this model.
But I think that for us it is okay, going
back to the bones. The process in skeletal
animation begins by transforming the position of
a vortex which is given as usual in local space,
while the model is in Bind Pose to the
coordinate system of a bone that influences it.
From there. We transform it to the bone space
of the parent and we continue until we get to
the root of the hierarchy. At the end of the
process, we are back at local space, which is
where the root is defined. And we can continue
to hold and view space as usual. Now there is
a small twist here with SMP known as the global
inverse transform, which you may have heard of,
and I will talk about it later. Since each
vertex is often influenced by more than one bone,
we actually need to do a weighted average
of the transformations of several bones.
Each bone transformation will be calculated in
the same way by going back from the bone all the
way to the root. In addition to that, we also need
to tweak the transformation of each node. As time
progresses, otherwise, there won't be any movement
to actually implement this process. SMP provides
us with two matrices. The first one is called
the offset matrix, and it is part of the bone
structure, which also contains all the weights for
the vertices. This matrix transforms from local
space directly into bone space, and it already
contains all the transformations that go from the
root down to the bone. So you don't need to worry
about the hierarchy. When you use this matrix.
The official documentation says that the offset
matrix transforms from mesh space to bone space
in Bind Pose, which is basically saying that if
you take a vertex in local space, while the model
is in Bind Pose, and you multiply it by the offset
matrix of a bone, you will get the coordinates of
the vertex in reference to that bone. This means
that if two bones influence the same vertex,
then by multiplying the vertex position by
the offset matrix of each bone separately,
you will get two different coordinates
in reference to the two bone spaces.
Of course, you will need to go back from
each bone to the root and calculate the final
matrix for each bone. If you transform
the vertex by the two final matrices,
and assuming that both bones are moving, you
will get to different positions in local space,
which is why we do a weighted average of the two
final matrices to get a position somewhere between
the two bones. For the next example, I've created
the world's simplest skeleton in blender with the
standard box at the origin, and the single bone
which is aligned with the y axis which is green.
As you can see, the Zed axis of the bone points
up, which is actually the default in Blender,
I exported the model in the setup to keep it
simpler otherwise blender will add transformations
from its own coordinate system to the one that
we are using. And it will complicate the analysis
back to our SNP sandbox. In the function bar
single bone, I've added a call to print SNP matrix
using the M offset matrix attribute of the bone as
a parameter, print SNP matrix is defined appear,
and it is very simple, it just prints the matrix
nicely. Now let's run this on the model single
bone dot FBX x which is in the Git repo, we
can see that we're getting the identity matrix
as the offset matrix. The reason is, of course,
that the base of the bone is at the origin of
the local space and the axis of the bone space are
aligned with those of local space. So transforming
from local space to bone space basically means
doing nothing, it's the same system. Let's see
another example. I've added a child bone that
extends the root bone along the y axis, we can
see in blender that the root bone is located at
the origin and the end of the bone is at one unit
on the Y the child bones starts in the same
location and ends at two units on the y. If we run
this using the sandbox, we can see that the offset
matrix of the parent is still the identity matrix.
But the offset matrix of the child will translate
us one unit along the negative y axis. And this
makes sense because this bone space is shifted one
unit on the positive y so in order to transform
one vertex, for example, this one right
here, which in local space is a two on the Y
to the bone space of the child, we need to
subtract one unit from the Y because the
vertex is closer to the base of the bone than to
the origin. I have one last example here called
to bones translation rotation dot F BX where
the child bone has been rotated 45 degrees up
and we can see that the offset matrix of the child
is very similar to a matrix that we have developed
in the past. So I will leave this up to you as
homework to explore. Okay, I hope that everything
up until this point made sense. So we can now
take a look at the second matrix which is located
at the new section of the SMP scene. This is the
node hierarchy. The node represents an entity
in the scene that has location and orientation
relative to a parent. And entity can be meshes,
bones, and even cameras and lighting, you can
actually design an entire scene in Blender
and export it with the camera in lighting, and
then load it with the same p. I may do a video
about it in the future. But for now let's just
focus on the bones. The node hierarchy starts
with a single root node, and each node includes
an array of pointers to zero or more children
and an array of pointers to zero or more measures.
This allows you to have a single mesh in your
model file and place it in different locations in
the world using multiple nodes. As you can see, it
is very simple to create the graph that we talked
about earlier. Using this node structure. There is
also a pointer to a single parent and the matrix
called M transformation. The job of this matrix
is to transform a vector to the coordinate system
of its parent. So this is like the transformation
from the coordinate system of the earth to the
coordinate system of the sun. After we multiply
position vector by the offset matrix, we find
ourselves in the coordinate system of the bone.
The next step is to find the corresponding node
in the graph, apply the transformation matrix of
this node and continue all the way to the root.
by traversing the parent attribute of the node.
The bones are mapped to the nodes. Simply using
their names you search for the name of the bone
in the node hierarchy until you find the node with
the same name. Let's explore the node hierarchy
using our SNP sandbox. In the parsing
function. I've added a call to parse hierarchy
which I will now uncomment this function takes
the scene as a parameter, and then calls parse
node using the m root node attribute of the
scene, parse node, for instance, the number
of meshes and children in the node as well as the
M transformation matrix event reverses the graph
downwards by recursively, calling parse node on
each of its children. Okay, so now let's test it.
On the first example, single bone dot F bx, we
can see that the root node is the identity matrix,
it has two children, the cube and the armature,
the transformation matrix of the armature
switches the Y and Zed axis, and also flipped the
sign of the y coordinate. Okay, interesting. The
armature contains a node called bone. And you
can see that the M transformation matrix here
does exactly the reverse. It's which is the Y
and Zed axis again, and flips the sign of the
Zed coordinate, which was previously the y. Okay,
so they're basically cancelling each other out.
If we multiply these matrices together, we can
verify that we're getting the identity matrix.
So I actually posted the question about it on the
SFP forum. And I will let you know when I get an
answer, there is actually an additional node here
called bone and which I guess, is for the tail of
the bone, but there isn't an actual bone for
this node. So the hierarchy may include nodes
that don't have a corresponding bone. But if
these nodes have children, then they will have
an effect on them. And we will need to take care
of that the transformation of bone and translates
one unit on the Y axis. And this makes sense,
because bone and also defines a coordinate system.
So if you multiply the origin of this coordinate
system 000 by this matrix, you will get 010 which
is the location of bone and in the coordinate
system of bone. So this is a trivial example,
but it helps us feel how the hierarchy works.
If we run this on a real model, like our good
old Bob lamb clean, we can see a much more
complex hierarchy. We have the root here,
then MD five hierarchy, origin, pubis, pelvis,
spine, neck and head. The transformations here are
too complex. So let's just hope it will all work
out correctly. The next step is to integrate the
two matrices into our skinned mesh class. All this
and more will be covered in the next tutorial.
Today, we're going to integrate the two matrices
that we got introduced to in the previous video,
the offset and the transformation into our
skinned mesh class. This includes two steps.
First, we need to transform the vertex from local
space to bone space using the offset matrix. Next,
we need to multiply the bone space position by
the transformation matrix of the node and continue
multiplying while traversing all the way to the
top of the hierarchy. This will bring us back
to local space. So we started in Local space and
we ended up in local space. So what has changed?
Well, basically nothing. In this tutorial,
we are still not applying the animation data,
which is what actually animates the model. We're
just applying the base transformations calculated
somewhere between blender and si p. So the
expectation is that we will get the model back
in Pause mode. Now remember that in addition to
the matrices, we're going to use the weights to
perform a weighted average of the transformations.
So this result is far from negligible. It's
an important milestone on the way to our final
destination. Okay, so let's review the changes
in the skinned mesh class. And we begin with
skinned mesh dot h, I've added a public function
called get bone transforms, this function will be
called in the Render loop. It basically calculates
all the transformations for all the bones and
returns them in a vector of matrices, which the
caller must supply as a reference. Each bone has
a single matrix which we can access in the vector
using its bone ID. In the final implementation,
this function also takes the current time
is a parameter, and then it returns a
different set of matrices in each call,
based on the current posture of the model.
In this tutorial, we still don't need it.
So I dropped it for now, in the private section,
I've added a function called Read node hierarchy.
I'll talk more about this function when we get to
the implementation of this class. I've also added
the SMP importer object, and the pointer to the a
scene object as private attributes. And the reason
is that we will need to access the hierarchy in
the scene. during runtime, when I tried to do it
in the previous implementation, where the importer
was a local variable in the function load mesh,
I got a segmentation fault. So I guess that we
need to keep the importer alive throughout the
execution. And finally, we have a structure called
Bone info, which stores a couple of matrices,
we have the bone offset matrix, which is here
for easy access. File transformation stores the
intermediate results of the whole transformation
chain so that when the entire process is complete,
we just grab it from here and return it to the
application. The constructor of this class takes
the offset matrix has a parameter, it stores it
in the corresponding member. And it initializes
the transformation matrix to zero. And of course,
we also have a vector of bone infrastructures,
one structure for each bone. Okay, so
this concludes the changes in the header.
As always, you can compare this file to the
previous version, actually, in part two,
because in part three, we only touch the sandbox,
and you'll be able to see all of these changes.
Now let's take a look at the CPP file, we
have a minor change in the load mesh function.
Instead of the local variables for the importer
in the scene, we have the new private attributes
in the class, so we will use them the next
change is in the load single bone function.
After we get the bone ID we check whether it
equals to the size of the bone in for vector.
If this turns out to be true, we know that this
is a new bone, because the bone IDs are a running
index. In that case, we create a bone info object
using the M offset matrix from the AI bone class.
Remember that in addition to the weights, the
SMP AI bone class also has this offset matrix.
After we initialize the bone info object, we push
it into the vector. This means that we can access
the bone information using the bone index. At
the bottom of this file, we have the two new
functions. First, we have get bone transforms,
which takes reference to a vector of matrices.
We start by resizing this vector using the
number of bone infrastructures that we have.
Next, we initialize the local matrix to be the
identity matrix. And we call Read node hierarchy
using the root node of the scene. And this matrix,
after Read node hierarchy returns, we should have
the transformations that we need in the final
transformation member of the bone info vector.
So all we need to do is to copy these matrices to
the vector supplied by the color. Now let's take a
look at the Read node hierarchy function. Which is
a bit tricky because it is a recursive function.
It takes a pointer to an AI node object and
the reference to a parent matrix. The first
call to this function is done using the root
node of the hierarchy and the identity matrix.
We start by creating a no transformation matrix
using the N transformation matrix from the node.
Next, we create a global transformation matrix by
multiplying the parent matrix with this matrix.
So we're actually traversing the graph from top to
bottom rather than from the node back to the root,
because this global matrix is going to be used
in the calculation of all of its children, so by
going from top to bottom, we can calculate it
only once. Note that we're taking advantage of
the associativity nature of matrix multiplication,
that tells us that as long as we keep the order of
the matrices, we can change the location of the
parentheses. Next, we check if we have a bone
that matches the name of the node, all the bones
of the corresponding node in the hierarchy. But
there may be nodes without bones, we already have
a map between bone names in their indices. So this
is very easy to do. If we find such a bone, we
update its final transformation to be the result
of multiplying gets offset matrix by the global
matrix, which basically captures the entire chain
from the node back to the root. Finally, we
traverse the children of the current node,
and we call Read node hierarchy recursively on
each child node with the global transformation
matrix in the second parameter. So as we go
deeper into the graph, this global transformation
encapsulates more and more M transformation
matrices. Let's take a look at the changes in the
application code. And this is very simple. In the
render function, we define a vector of matrices,
we get the bone transformations from the mesh,
and we loop over the vector that we got back,
we set the matrices into the skinning technique
one by one. This is a very simple function that
updates the uniform array in the shader, so
I'll skip it and you can take a look at it
later. The last change is in the vertex shader,
we have a new uniform called G bones. This is
an array of 100 matrices, so make sure this is
enough. For the models that you plan to load.
In the main function, we create a bone transfer
matrix as a weighted average of the matrices of
all the bones that influence the current vertex,
we use the bone IDs of the vertex to access the
bone uniform array. Take a look at Part Two if you
don't remember, where the bone ideas came from,
each bone matrix is multiplied
by the corresponding weight,
which is also a vertex attribute. If the number of
bones is less than four, the weight will be zero,
so the calculation will have no effect. We sum
up the results of all these multiplications
to get the final bone transformation and we use
it to transform the vertex from local space back
into local space again, once we integrate the
animation data, the position will be different
than the original. The shader continues as
usual by multiplying the updated local position
by the W VP matrix, there is actually no change in
the fragment shader. So this concludes this video.
The next step is to integrate the animation
data so we can finally see something moving.
All this and more will be
covered in the next tutorial.
Welcome to the fifth and final part of the
skeletal animation tutorial miniseries,
okay, so basically, this means that we need to get
the animation working by the end of this video.
But first, let's do a quick checkup
of what we already know about the
relevant SNP data structures. The AI scene
class has a list of meshes and each mesh
has a list of bones for each bone. In
addition to the weights and the offset matrix,
we also have a corresponding node in the node
hierarchy. The node has a transformation matrix
that gets us to the coordinate system of its
parent. In the previous tutorial, we saw how
these two matrices work together, so make sure
to watch that video first. The ice in class
also has an array of AI animation structures. Each
structure represents the full animation sequence,
such as running, fighting, or whatever
the character can do. There are a couple
of time related attributes in this structure,
we have m duration, which is the length of the
animation in text and empty x per second, which is
basically the intended frame rate of the animation
set by the artist. So for example, if the frame
rate is 30, and your game is running at 60 frames
per second, you will need to interpolate an extra
frame between two consecutive animation frames,
and vice versa. If the game is slower than the
animated model, we will need to skip frames to
keep up the intended pace of the animation.
Obviously, if we divide the duration by x
per second, we get the length of the animation in
actual seconds. The most important attribute in AI
animation is an array of AI node and M structures
called M channels. The size of the array array is
given in M num channels. Each animated node in the
hierarchy has a corresponding entry in this array.
So if we go into the declaration of AI node nm,
we can see that it has a member called M node
name. In order to find the animation data for
a specific node in the hierarchy, we just need
to find its name. In the M channels array. The
animation parameters themselves are given in
three separate arrays, position and scaling are
given in vectors and the rotation is a quaternion.
Each array can theoretically have a different
length, which is why we have num position keys,
num rotation keys and num scaling keys.
In our example, we have 140 Position and
Rotation entries, and no scaling. The code must
be flexible. To handle all the available cases,
AI vector key and AI quad key are actually a pair
of attributes that represent the transformation.
And the time it takes in which this transformation
should take place. The keys are guaranteed to be
sorted in their chronological order. So searching
for the current time simply means reversing
the array until we find the time range between
two consecutive keys in which the current time
is located. Assuming that the current time
will usually land between two keys, we must
interpolate between the animation parameters of
these two keys. After we interpolate the animation
parameters, we combine the scaling rotation and
translation into a single transformation matrix.
And that's basically it. So now let's jump into
the code and see how to actually implement it.
This time, I'd like to start in the application
code where we have a minor change, and that is
the tracking of time. I've added a new private
attribute for the start time in milliseconds.
And when we are finished with the init
function, we initialize it by calling
Get Current Time in Milly's. This function is
defined in common slash O GL dev utils dot cpp.
And you can see that we actually have a different
implementation for Windows and Linux. On Windows,
we use get account and on Linux, we use get time
of day. Both of these functions are very simple,
and you can check out the documentation on your
own for more details. Now, there are also high
resolution timers that you can use if you need
more precision, but I'm okay with the millisecond
level. Okay, so in the render function, we just
need to call Get Current Time in Milly's again,
and calculate the delta between the startup
time and the current time and that will give
us the time that the application has been running.
Notice that we divide the result by 1000 here and
cast it to float. So we get the animation time in
seconds with possible fractions. Between seconds,
we provide the animation time to get bone
transforms, so that we can calculate the
correct transformations for the current point in
time. Okay, so while recording, I forgot to tell
you that get bone transforms needs to convert the
time in seconds into ticks, because the same piece
specifies the start time for each frame in ticks.
We do this by multiplying the timing seconds
by the number of ticks per second. The ticks per
second can be found in the AI animation structure.
And in case it was not set by the modeling
software, we set it to 25 by default, which
is simply the value that I saw in the SMP sources.
The next step depends on the logic of your game.
If you want to run the animation sequence once
you need to reset the start time at the point
where the animation is supposed to start. In this
demo, I want the animation to run again and again.
So I'm using F mod to do a floating point
model operation of the current time in ticks,
and the duration of the animation. This
divide the entire execution of the demo
into segments of M duration length, and in the
animation time in ticks, we get the current time
within that segment. Now let's jump directly
into the implementation of the skin mesh class.
And in part three, I mentioned the global
inverse transform, so I want to talk about
it for a second. The idea is that in some models
that are loaded by SMP, the transformation matrix
of the root node may actually be the world
transformation of the object. This allows
you to place the object in the world already in
Blender. In that case, we need to bring the object
back into local space, apply the animation
in local space and then transform the object
back to wherever you want it to be. In order to
do that, we need to reverse the transformation
of the root node and apply that the end of the
entire transformation chain. So after we load the
model, we grab the M transformation matrix of the
root node. We store it in a new Private attribute
called M global inverse transform, and we call the
inverse function in order to inverse this matrix.
The inverse function is defined in math 3d
dot cpp. And this is a standard implementation
of matrix inversion, which you can find in
many resources online. So no big deal here,
the global inverse transform is used
in the Read node hierarchy function,
you can see that I've added it to the head of the
transformation chain. So the final transformation
of a bone is first the offset matrix to go
from local space to bone space. Then we have
the global transform, which caps captures all the
node transformations to the root of the hierarchy,
and finally, the inverse global matrix. Okay, I
hope this makes sense. Now let's jump back to the
top of this function, we get the animation time
in seconds as a parameter from the application.
The next thing we need to do is to access the
animation sequence that we're interested in.
In this tutorial, I'm keeping it
simple. So I use the first animation
by default. But if you know that your model
has several animations, you can search for
the one you want in the animation array. Next, we
need to search inside the AI animation structure
for the AI node nm that matches the current node.
And we do this in the Find node and in function,
which is defined right here, it takes the AI
animation structure and the name of the node,
and it simply traverses the channels in
the animation until it finds the one that
matches the name of the node. In that case, it
returns the matching AI node enum structure.
Not all nodes are animated. And in that case,
we return now, back to read node hierarchy. If
another dimension data was found, we calculate the
transformation matrix. For the animation, we're
going to cover the calculation in just a bit. But
before we do that, I want you to pay attention to
something which is very important. When the
current node has animation data, we override
the no transformation matrix which was initial
initialized by the entrance formation matrix
from the graph. And the explanation for that
can be found in the documentation that tells us
that the transformation matrix computed from
these values replaces the nodes original
transformation matrix at a specific time. This
means all keys are absolute and not relative
to the bone default pose. Okay, so if you
expected the animation matrix to be applied,
on top of the no transformation, that is not the
case, if the node is not animated, we continue the
process with the transformation matrix from the
graph. But if it does have animation, we have to
override this matrix with the one that we're going
to calculate. So you want to be careful here,
otherwise it will get garbage. The transformation
matrix of the animation is calculated
by initializing three separate matrices for the
scaling, rotation and translation, and combining
them as usual, into a single matrix. For example,
let's see how the scaling matrix is calculated.
We prepare a vector for the scaling and notice
that I'm using the SNP vector structure here, AI
vector 3d, we call calc interpolated scaling with
the scaling vector, the animation time and the
node animation structure. This function starts by
checking the number of scaling keys that we have.
If there's only one key, there is no room for any
interpolation, so we just return the value of the
first key. If there is more than one key, we need
to find the key that matches the current time.
The keys are sorted by time. So we need to find
the first key whose time is greater than the
current time and we need to interpolate between
that key and the one just before that. To do that,
we have fine scaling, which traverses all
the scaling keys in the AI node nm structure,
and compares the current time to the time in the
key. Notice that the for loop starts at zero and
stops at one key before the end, because we're
actually checking the key at i plus one. And if
the animation time is smaller than that time,
we return the index i back to calc interpolated
scaling. Once we have the index of the correct
key, the next index is the one that we found
plus one, we have to interpolate between these two
keys. And this is standard linear interpolation,
we calculate the delta time between the two keys.
And the interpolation factor is the range between
the beginning of the time range that we found
and the current time divided by the length of
the range itself. So this will give us a factor
between zero and one depending on how close we
are to the edges of the range. Okay, so
if we're very close to the beginning,
the factor will be close to zero and if we're
almost at the end factor will be close to one,
the way that we actually use the factor is by
grabbing the scaling vectors from the two indices,
calculating the range between them. And then the
result is the starting value plus the product of
the factor and the delta k. So this allows us to
smoothly interpolate between the scaling vectors,
especially when the game is running at a higher
frame rate than what the model was originally
designed for. Going back to read node hierarchy,
you can see that we use the interpolated scaling
vector to initialize the standard scaling
matrix, calculating the interpolated rotation
and translation is exactly the same. The
only thing worth mentioning here is that
interpolating the two quaternions is done using
the SMP interpolate function, which is part of
the AI quaternion class. We also normalize the
quaternion before we return it to the color,
we combine the three transformation matrices
together in the standard order which you
can also see in the documentation, scaling,
rotation and then translation. And that's it.
So this completes the mini
series on skeletal animation.
I hope you enjoyed it as much as
I did, please hit the like button
subscribe, feel free to comment below
and they'll see you in the next tutorial.